Hello?
Freak bitches.
Okay,
so first of all,
let's do rock,
paper,
scissors to see who goes first.
Okay.
So you today.
Ready?
Yeah.
One,
two,
three.
Oh No,
no,
you're doing know what you're doing.
Let me do it.
I'll do the cow.
I'll do the count.
You guys get your hands up.
Ready?
One,
two,
three.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Burt one,
that one.
Okay.
One,
two,
three.
Okay,
one,
two,
three.
Gotcha.
Okay,
Burt wins.
So would you like to go first?
Would you like Tom Igoe first?
I'd like to weigh in first.
Okay,
I'm so fucking thirsty.
so we're gonna move over to a Tom's microphone over there.
Do you have a wide shot?
Yeah,
we can get the whole room.
We're going to use that camera up there.
So we'll be using that camera up here.
Here we go.
Are we doing this one carpet?
Do we want you to take your clothes off?
First of all,
you definitely want to take your clothes off.
Well I know it works.
Hold on like I know,
but let's make sure we know exactly if it's exactly right cause it may not be
like my scale at home.
I'm always around 200 pounds.
Two Oh one.
So I'm two oh one with my clothes on and she was like one night he's got a
rubber suit on the whole deal.
Okay.
So,
uh,
for folks that are just listening here,
we're in the studio here and Jamie is setting up the camera for you too so that
it will point directly down at the scale.
Bert is looking considerably slimmer,
considerably slimmer.
He's got multiple layers on and now he's down to underwear,
which are probably wet.
He took the first layer of underwear off.
Socks,
a drum roll.
Ladies and gentlemen.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp
bomp bomp bomp bomp he's drying himself off like a wrestling tournament.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
here we go.
Below two 27 everybody,
Bert Kreischer called out.
Joe
Two 21.
Holy Shit.
Oh No.
But it's right.
I checked my own weight.
It's right.
This is what I use at home too,
but we can,
we can chat.
It was 220130530 four points.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it to 21 to 21,
ladies and gentlemen.
Holy Shit.
I mean,
now my shit.
And then Joe,
my prediction was Tommy wasn't going to take his shirt off her way and he's got
two now.
That's shirt is precious ounces to 21 my man went hard book.
Yes,
I have my watch on.
That's probably at least a few ounces.
That's a good watch.
It's a beautiful watch.
But I'm going to make a drink.
Oh,
you're going to drink while it's going on.
Oh goodness.
This is,
this is chaos.
Here we go.
Tommy looking very slim to,
here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
show fuck.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
First of all,
congratulations to the both of you.
Fuck that is,
that's gigantic.
I'm so thirsty.
It's ridiculous.
We got some coconut water.
If you want to get some electrolytes in you.
Holy Shit.
You guys want to coconut water?
No,
no,
I'm good.
God,
you want to go get water or the calories in this?
Uh,
no,
not at all.
It's a Stevia.
It's called via Zvm Guy Sodium Tommy.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
So those extra pounds,
like whatever,
you know,
you didn't drink water that home made up for it.
God Damn it.
We gotta do this all again tomorrow of weight.
What happens tomorrow?
Let's take tomorrow.
We're,
let's look at question one.
Victory.
Well here man.
What's it now?
Okay,
we go,
we got this out of the way.
Oh my God.
So thirsty.
Wow.
So let's just cut the shit and get right to the way we go.
Right to the fucking way I should weigh in first cause I have a feeling that,
okay,
don't be a pussy.
Don't be scared.
Okay folks,
Jesus.
Oh by the way,
we did the height tests,
uh,
because Ari Shaffir,
who was supposed to pay if they got a low two 27,
are you supposed to pay for their trip?
The loser has to shave their beard and the loser has to pay for the winners trip
of their choice IX.
Unless they can get down to two 27.
And which Arusha fear agreed that he was going to pay.
But now our is bogging and he's saying that they have to be,
uh,
their,
their height has to be measured because the body mass index would indicate that
they have to be a certain height or they're obese.
It was really weird.
So we,
we tested the heights.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
Tom is just under six feet tall and for all you assholes at Sam five foot two,
we tested me too.
I'm five,
eight and up cunt hair.
Um,
and Burt is taller than Tom,
so birds.
Good.
You're about six one.
So the body mass index.
I think you dropped dude.
You look good.
Get on here.
You might have it.
All right.
So Burt was at two 21 yesterday.
You look significantly thinner today.
I feel her hurting.
Okay.
He's hurt.
And let's see,
he's getting on the scale.
Two 24 to 20 for Burke for one pound,
one pound less.
One fucking pound.
I think Tommy's got it here.
Let's see here.
Fuck.
Say Goodbye.
Say Goodbye to Hollywood.
I'm on me.
He's going to Paris for a soccer game.
Please have gained weight.
Okay,
you fucking do.
Tom Gets it running away.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have a winner in the Hashtag who is fat contest.
The winner is Thompson girl down to 216 fucking pounds.
Outrageous,
outrageous coconut waters.
C Two oh coconut waters must be consumed now get those electrolytes in your
system,
boys.
Well done.
Amazing effort.
It's not easy to lose weight.
It's really not easy to lose it the way you guys did it.
Two days in a row,
man.
Crazy shit.
That was the that yet.
Today was the hardest workout I've ever had.
It ran eight miles last one fucking palm.
That's crazy.
I think my body was like in shock.
That's what happens.
That's what happens to fighters.
It,
it shuts down.
So have a seat.
Guys pulled it off.
I've been thinking about that.
Drink this entire fucking day.
Beard,
we've got a beard trimmer over there at charging it up.
I should probably a shave your beard after you have some pizza.
I mean have a live a little,
I'm going to have a hard time eating pizza with his fat fucking face.
It's not going to look good.
Flat white man got so fat.
Yeah,
you look pretty fucking skinny today,
man.
You did.
You do look significantly Skinner.
You skinny skinnier today.
I don't know man.
I think you a little distended yesterday with that pulled pork and your stomach
from the night before or the night before for the Waynes.
Wayne's Collard Greens pulled pork.
I won though.
Seriously?
What is that long strand DNA?
That Mickey mantle jeans.
I gotta be honest with you.
Derek Jeter,
you showed a little Mickey mail today.
How did you get down to two 16?
What did you do different?
Do you want to,
it's so funny.
Three,
he said something in passing and that's what I did.
What?
But I just didn't acknowledge it.
He goes,
uh,
she go to Burke Williams and just sweat it out in the spa.
That's what I've been doing for two days.
I just can't eat today.
I just come out of fluids today and then fucking go to Berkeley and sweated out.
How you feeling,
Bro?
I feel like a chain.
I want to give a shout out to God how to him and nothing's,
none of this is possible.
And then,
uh,
Jake Smith.
Thank you Jake.
Who's Jake?
He's a fighter who gave me all this insight on,
ah,
oh,
cool.
Jake's,
go fuck yourself.
Shout out to it's anybody.
Oh my God.
Can you do this?
[inaudible].